dieses video
achterbahn youtuber sein und von seiner
leidenschaft zu leben war schon fast
immer mein traum und da geht es vielen
meine zuschauer ähnlich deswegen wurde
schon häufiger vorgeschlagen ein video
zu machen indem ich von grund auf
versuche einen youtube-kanal hoch zu
ziehen um herauszufinden ob ich das noch
mal könnte wie viel glück dabei eine
rolle spielt das einzige problem ja also
irgendwie kennen sein gesicht hat schon
so ein paar leute auf die tiere wurden
wäre es halt gar nicht repräsentativ
weil ich ja von null anfangen möchte man
kann ein gesicht aber natürlich auch
meine stimme und dass das kann man ja
wohl kaum ändern oder oder und ob man
das kann widing ist der neueste heiße
scheiß und erinnert sehr stark an ray
player one es gibt ganze online
existenzen die ganz normale displays
oder columbus mit anderen youtuber
machen nur dass niemand weiß wer da
eigentlich dahintersteckt theoretisch
könnte das hier ein 50-jähriger kerl
sein oder ein 23-jähriger kehrt alles
dank modernster technik die mittlerweile
scheinbar so zugänglich ist das ist
einfach jeder machen kann und damit kann
ich jetzt einen komplett neuen youtube
und twitter kanal machen und schauen wie
viele follower jus oder vielleicht sogar
nächstens ich in einer woche als
virtueller charakter bekommen das kann
ja was werden
dieses video wird unterstützt von blue
mikrofon am ende des videos könnt ihr
ein richtig geiles tat das herz für
content creators gewinnen also bleibt
dran die kniffligste frage wird jetzt
eigentlich um einen avatar also meine
fake identität eigentlich aussehen soll
eisenmann sein oder eine frau oder ein
roboter auf alle fälle muss ich um nicht
erkannt zu werden nicht nur mein gesicht
verändern sondern auch meine stimme und
dafür habe ich mir jetzt mal so im
wolfcenter programm installiert
das ist meine richtige stimme
in der verrückte gibt es viele
verschiedene stimmen verzerre da ich
mich halt ein wenig roboter
der doktor was immer das ist
[Musik]
menschen
in den spitzenspielen
bummeln sich hier
anhören dass frauen nicht wirklich das
ist was sagt
[Musik]
jetzt ja nur noch hinaussehen oder
passend zu meiner neuen stimme okay man
schauen was internet ausspuckt sehr sehr
viel animiert zeug und sehr viel cartoon
mäßig das zweite kann sich aber auch mit
anschauen dann auch sehr viele tiere und
hier sogar indische gott hasst er
überwältigte sagen ich glaube ich kohle
wenn es ein bisschen realistischer wäre
also halt auch so halbwegs realistisches
licht wie zum beispiel micro als seine
roboter weiß ich auch dass wir auch
kraft das wäre schon auch richtig geil
aber das teil kostet 500 euro das muss
jetzt auch nicht sein dass da schon mal
nicht schlecht jetzt muss dieses 3d
modell nur noch zum leben erweckt und
animiert werden ursprünglich musste man
bei 3d charakteranimationen mühselig
jede bewegung einzeln an einer art
virtuellem skelett einprogrammieren was
erstens extrem zeitaufwändig ist und
zweitens auch nicht immer besonders
natürlich aussieht aus hollywood-filmen
kennt aber mittlerweile wohl jeder das
sogenannte motion capturing bei dem die
bewegungen eines menschen auf einen 3d
objekt angewandt werden und das können
mittlerweile auch privatpersonen ein
größerer video bei hat angeblich sogar
diesen anzug für um die 20.000 euro aber
es geht auch deutlich günstiger ich
werde dafür drei verschiedene geräte
nutzen und zwar zuallererst mein handy
fürs gesicht tracking das ist nicht
meine arbeit am handy
das ist schon mal wie die crazy
die da meinen augen auch trägt also das
jetzt mal so im direkten vergleich zu
sehen
john schon lustig hallo ich spreche
gerade eigentlich echt ziemlich abstrus
als nächstes müssen noch die kopf und
körperbewegungen getrackt werden und das
funktioniert mit einer simplen kamera
oder webcam wo mein gott wtf das jetzt
noch nicht mit den guten face tracking
aber nicht mit den händen aber
es ist super krise hat auch das ist
einfach so gut umgeht crazy das ist
verrückt er sieht es auch nicht mehr
realistisch aus aber ich befürchte dass
es das noch wird er da setzt richtig das
ist jetzt richtig happy test das einzige
was jetzt noch fehlt sind meine hände
und dazu habe ich dieses kleine gerät
hier gekauft das ding hier ist der
finger trecker okay also es trenc dass
mein gesicht
mehr oder weniger gut ist mein körper
das projekt uns auch irgendwie meine
hände dass sich so ein bisschen gruselig
aber es trägt einzel finger also nicht
schon mal richtig cool ist nur
das problem ist diese noch immer im kopf
also das soll natürlich nicht so sein
[Musik]
was ist das es muss schon noch das muss
noch besser gehen so groß ist es auch
schon mal
das erscheinungsbild stimmt also hier
seht ihr nun einige machina stimme
findungs tests essen kommen
von videos von youtube ok ich mit meinem
allerersten stream als wie die oberin
losgeht projekt mit dem namen namens
generator aber schafft er weiß
[Musik]
wie sie je sie einfach karriere kann
losgehen
so schnell so ein profilbild gemacht
denn er braucht extrem
[Musik]
schön weil ich sage aber schon jetzt
ich wäre als alles minecraft
gut also ich stelle mir jetzt nicht so
schön aber das ist doch längst vergessen
wenn man dieses wunderschöne aggressiven
lächeln gibt
kaum verstört schauen ob die welt bereit
ist für caprica ich bin jetzt gleich
eine rolle nicht mehr mit euch mit der
kamera mehr reden ich werde hier 40
zuschauer stream aber es trotzdem ultra
ultra wir das gefühl
entstehen ist zwar noch keine lust hat
mein erster stream ist ich bin jetzt die
allererste folge main kräftig
aber ich habe den bildschirm nicht
aufgenommen das heißt die unsägliche
peinlichkeit des ersten streams mit
einer fiktiven identität diese
peinlichkeit ist für immer verloren
erwarte gute nachrichten der zweite
stream der war ja genauso peinlich aber
erstmal wie fühlte sich der erste an und
damit haben jetzt auch unsere erste
nacht in minecraft überstanden ich bin
gespannt wie es weiter geht
[Musik]
so
das war's von stream das war also eine
super skurrile erfahrung ich wusste ja
dass mir keiner zugeschaut und für
keinen menschen also 40 zuschauer stream
man fühlt sich ja selber verrückt weil
man damit sie selber redet man sagen
super schwierig dass mit dieser youtuber
persönlichkeit zu machen und ja auch die
ganze zeit versuchen ihnen möglichst
wieder frau zu reden keine klaren ja zum
glück ist mir das nicht unangenehm
ja und dann würden dann auch noch
geboßelt mit 216 verloren die sind
glaube ich alle nicht echt auftritt
passiert das einfach mal dass man am
wasser gebaut werden voll oder zu kriegt
weil die dann irgendwie hoffen dass man
die zurück folgt oder irgend sowas
komisch ist wir hatten sechs einzelne
zuschauer insgesamt ich denke davon sind
vertreten parallel werden aber natürlich
den nächsten stream sehen wie sich das
entwickelt soll mal schauen sagen sie
jetzt diesmal dauert um als einzurichten
jetzt wo ich ja eigentlich theoretisch
schon alles parat
haben wir mal laden ich musste starten
muss das motion capturing cool stadt
mit ihren platz ich habe es wieder
komplett perfekten start in den job
wirklich unsere frage zeit fanden
unserem ein großprojekt wie gesagt immer
ist für mich ja auch einfach keine
beschreibung vor das ist
okay was denkt der denkt
[Musik]
okay ich glaube nicht dass mit den
fahrten nein
das war richtig richtig knapp ich habe
auch nichts mehr zu essen und was noch
insgesamt ist für mich aber gehören ist
frei
und dann hätten wir absichtlich jetzt
[Musik]
das video wird nun zusammen mit zooms
und musik geschnitten und auf einem
komplett frischen youtube kanal
hochgeladen der auch erst einmal
erstellt werden muss danach mache ich
diese reizen in posen wie sich das für
einen aufstrebenden influenza
schrägstrich video war so gehört wir
starten mit 0,0 abonnenten und 0,0
aufrufen ich habe den account auch mit
niemandem geteilt das heißt jegliche
interaktion ist komplett anonym und
natürlich
jetzt heißt es warten und jeden tag
einmal stream dass daraus geschnittene
video auf youtube laden und schauen ob
sich zuschauer ansammeln der dritte film
geht los ich bin ich man ab heute in den
tod kommt ich will ja schon geld zu
schauen
wir sind skeptisch werden zusammen mit
der steam community erleben wir also
aufregende abenteuer also konkret heißt
das es verirren sich drei einzelne leute
in meinen stream und niemand schreibt in
den chat und heute gab es auch kein
follower daran hier die nations zu
bekommen und sogar geld zu verdienen
daran können wir derzeit noch überhaupt
nicht denken tag 4 mittlerweile fest mir
echt viel leichter als frau mit
verstellter stimme zu reden das heißt
nicht dass das ergebnis irgendwie besser
ist weil das ist es auf gar keinen fall
aber es hat jetzt leicht einfach durch
zusammen mit anderen zuschauern und
immerhin kommunikation bisher minecraft
zu spielen was ich eigentlich schon
immer zumindest ende auf youtube
formieren sich die klicks ganz langsam
die videos bekommen alle interviews und
ich denn auch wirklich sicher dass sie
nicht von mir kommen hier sind 25 news
494 sogar 20 ist er wirklich werde in
diesem video lustige interaktionen der
zuschauer und im livestream haben aber
passiert bis jetzt hat einfach gar nicht
so und heute schriftlich zum
allerletzten mal eine ganz andere
gestalten und damit herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren mal minecraft
reichweite aufbauen von null an ist sehr
schwer wenn man auf youtube ein video
hochlädt und man keine abonnenten hat
bekommt es natürlich erstmal views
ich meine wann habt ihr das letzte mal
wieder angeschaut das unter 100 klicks
hat am ende hat man meist geklickte das
video immerhin 30 aufrufe und alle
videos insgesamt zusammen sogar 50 und
davon hat sogar eine abonniert hat mich
persönlich war es nicht diesen
riesenportionen challenger auf jeden
fall gewachsen bin die technik dahinter
die ich jetzt gelernt damit diese motion
capturing finde ich auch super geil und
die wenn man mit sicherheit noch mal für
irgendein anderes will das projekt
verwenden ja und ich dachte eigentlich
schon dass wir eigentlich leute in den
trip chat kriegen wo wir dann vielleicht
so ein bisschen drauf in spielen können
das video nations kriegen und damit
irgendwie was für die ihn aber nur zum
testen einfach nur sondern auch das
funktioniert das system hier
offensichtlich gar nicht 00 euro
verdient die bots die uns auftritt
schreien gefolgt haben sie wollen
übrigens in der komplett gelöscht was er
auch richtig ist allerdings wurde auch
der eine richtige follower den wir
ehrlich und tat arbeitet haben auch
einmal gelöscht und jetzt haben wir
einfach null wenn ihr jetzt aber
wirklich mit eurem youtube kanal oder
social media generell durchstarten oder
ein bisschen promo von mir haben möchtet
dann hergehört drei von euch können
jetzt dieses mikrofon das blue tec sowie
den passenden namen compass und den job
absorbiere radius gewinn also ein
komplettes staates heißt dass man
einfach per usb an seinem pc ansteckt
und dann soll jetzt wohnqualität hat wie
ich jetzt gerade ihr müsst ihr nur ein
30 sekündiger video machen und auf
youtube hochladen in dem wir richtig
zackig cool geschnitten und mit musik
aus social media konzept vorstellt egal
ob youtube twitter oder film zeigt in
euren tipp auch unbedingt ausschnitte
von eurer arbeit falls es da schon mal
zu sehen gibt und stellt ansonsten in
dem video ein möglichst kreatives kanal
konzept vor ort mit grafiken bildern und
alle möglichen anschließend reagiere ich
auf meinem zweiten mal auf die zehn bis
zwanzig besten einsendungen die dann
sogar ein bisschen promo von mir kriegen
und die top 3 gewinnen dann das blue atx
plus zubehör alle teilnahmebedingungen
findet ihr ein video beschreibung
wieder macht gut
[Musik]